how does it benefit him to stay with all
of these women does he consider them
trophies sister wife star Gwendolyn
Brown doesn't hold back calling out her
dad Cody it's more I I'm not the kind of
person who I this is the way that I am
in my life Gwendolyn calls it like she
sees it in her latest YouTube recap of
her family's reality show the 21 year
old daughter of Cody and Christine
watches back footage and gets upset over
how her dad treated his first wife Mary
I want to work on the relationship but
Cody has basically said that he doesn't
does that mean we're just not married
anymore he's a poop for that that's not
how I consider it very I don't really
consider myself married to Mary
I wanted to move on and marry another
she wouldn't get an argument with me
then stop and don't believe that we can
ever be functional the thing is he's
just leaving her on at this point and I
don't believe that I will ever be
emotionally safe with her then tell her
oh my God ahead of Cody and Mary split
which was announced in December things
were Rocky for years especially
following her 2015 catfish Scandal I
thought I was talking to a man online
it wasn't a man
it was a woman
pretending to be a man
I'm not mad anymore I'm Not Angry
Anymore I'm not hurt anymore
so you know that's real progress despite
Cody pushing Mary away she continued
fighting to save their relationship my
strength is sticking around and seeing
if Cody would be willing to work on a
relationship so I leave that door open
but I'm not pining away for it and
Gwendolyn she thinks her dad's in the
wrong for giving Mary hope he's just
letting Mary believe in this like
fantasy that he's created that they can
somehow work on their relationship which
is like manipulative it's it feels
completely manipulative to me how does
it benefit him to stay with all of these
women does he consider them trophies
does he consider them like his path into
heaven and I'm just glad that ones that
needed to get out of that situation have
gotten out of that situation as season
17 played out Christine Mary and
Janelle's relationships with Cody all
ended Robin who's legally married to
Cody is the only one left nobody's a
prisoner in this family and since Mary
went her own way she's living life to
the fullest and as for me lately I've
been focusing Less on doing what they
say I can't do and more on doing
whatever the hell I want earlier this
month Mary shared this video canoeing
with a friend and if that audio sounds
familiar it's Taylor Swift's acceptance
speech from the 2019 billboard women in
Music Awards and as for me lately I've
been focusing Less on doing what they
say I can't do and more on doing
whatever the hell I want
Mary's caption building businesses
building friendships building a great
life all while doing whatever the hell I
want
[Music]